Vladimir Vladimirovitch ma question sera
liés à la sécurité et en particulier
menace terroriste
La Russie a toujours condamné tout
actes terroristes et continuent de le faire
condamner en particulier ceux qui
avoir lieu en Europe
par exemple cette année qui étaient
causé en réaction à la publication
dessins animés du prophète muhammad en même temps
fois que la Russie ne soutient pas l'édition
ces dessins animés, s'il vous plaît dites-moi
A votre avis, où est la frontière ?
entre la liberté d'expression qui est
droit inaliénable de tout être humain et
insultant les croyants et en relation avec
La Russie à notre pays s'il vous plaît dites-moi
que faisons-nous pour que cela ne nous arrive pas
voici ce scénario européen grâce à ceux
qui agissent sans réfléchir en portant atteinte aux droits
croyants leurs sentiments pas si vous devriez
rappelez-vous que ce qu'il aura
une sorte de réponse de
d'autre part, c'est une réponse non
doit être agressif et en tout
religions du monde, y compris
Christianisme dans l'islam, j'ai récemment
même cité une citation du sacré
écrits du Coran et pour les bibles d'autrefois
écritures sacrées des bouddhistes dans tous
toutes les religions du monde
signifie qu'il n'y a aucune trace d'agressivité avant
vos droits est de supposer que
lors du piétinement des droits, y compris la poussière
croyants
la réaction ne doit pas être
destiné à ôter la vie à une personne
jusqu'à ce qu'en principe
contredit l'esprit même de tout monde
Dieu a donné vie à la religion
et seul Dieu peut l'enlever
pays européens il y a des représentants
dis l'islam
représentent environ dix pour cent
de la population locale, mais ils ont généralement
immigrés ou migrant dans la seconde
troisième génération et nous avons quelque chose
des représentants de différentes confessions vivent
ils n'ont pas leur propre côté
c'est une autre patrie
c'est une caractéristique très importante
comment il s'est développé et
la relation s'est développée jusqu'à présent
entre représentants
dénominations dans notre pays et dire
Pays européens et et là donc là
ce projet de multiculturalisme
il souffrait
un fiasco à propos duquel beaucoup l'ont réclamé
le projet et la mise en œuvre de Kiev sont forcés
devaient avouer avoir avoué le fait qu'il
s'est effondré, et avec nous il s'est formé tout seul
nous-mêmes depuis des siècles, et nous sommes très
chérir